après plusieurs mois de traque le tueur
présumé de cette femme dans l'est
parisien a été arrêté aujourd'hui depuis
24 heures les policiers étaient à ses
trousses
l'unef en pleine confusion
françois léotard n'apprécie pas les
tentatives de françois bayrou pour créer
un nouveau parti pour cent des
spécialistes américains en vie la
variété de notre alimentation les
matières grasses le vin rouge sont les
garants de notre bonne santé avec
modération bien sûr du monde de football
la sécurité dans les stades objet de
toutes les inquiétudes les anglais
applique une méthode qui a fait ses
preuves
c'est notre enquête de ce soir l'un des
plus grands pianistes de jazz michel
petrucciani en tournée en france avec un
spectacle véritablement époustouflant
madame monsieur bonsoir le tueur en
série présumé de l'est parisien été
arrêté aujourd'hui au terme de plusieurs
mois d'enquêté laborieuse et d'une
traque de 24 heures qui a mobilisé près
de 400 policiers à paris l'homme âgé de
35 ans avait déjà dans le passé été
condamné à dix ans de prison pour viol
récemment encore il avait été arrêté
pour vol puis relâché et ce sont
notamment les tests génétiques d'adr
réalisé avec ses empreintes qui ont
permis son arrestation ce tueur en série
est accusée au total de sept meurtres de
jeunes femmes d'une tentative de meurtre
et d'un viol valérie fournis ou michel
le bassin le suspect numéro un
bientôt face à son juge dans les
couloirs du palais du justice un homme
en verve au crâne rasé
le présumé tueur en série de l'est
parisien les policiers connaissaient son
existence depuis plus de 15 ans
fiche anthropométrique guy georges 1 m
72 35 ans né à angers d'origine
antillaise c'est un enfant de la dass un
sdf et rendent hôtel miteux en foyer de
bienfaisance via les squats de la
capitale
recherché par toutes les polices depuis
24 heures il a été arrêté aujourd'hui à
11 heures dans un supermarché près de la
place blanche
l'un des témoins de la scène en tremble
encore et souhaite rester anonyme
il ya des messieurs qui ont claqué un
autre donc ils étaient tous enseignants
fed a pensé que c'était
c'étaient les policiers dans ce look ou
même j'ai pensé que c'était une bagarre
et quand je suis sorti les menottes j'ai
compris que c'était des flics et à
prêcher les avait sauté de joie j'ai
compris que c'était un gros coup avant
son arrestation pour ceux qui le
côtoyaient dit georges était un peu
monsieur tout le monde
il avait ses habitudes dans cette
association il venait régulièrement
touchées sont et rémy est retiré son
courrier très gentil très courtois très
avions il serait même venu ce matin
nous l'avons informée des demandes qui
étaient faites à son sujet qu'il est
bien qui dès qu'ils le pourraient ils
prendre à elle reprendrai contact guy
georges était comme l'on dit bien connu
des services de police
son casier judiciaire fait état de
nombreuses condamnations en 1983 18 mois
de prison pour attentat à la pudeur
sous la menace d'une arme à paris en
1995 85 10 ans pour viol à des violences
annonce en 82 et 92
il est mis en cause dans des affaires
d'atteintes sexuelles et relâché
soupçonné aussi en 95 dans une affaire
d'assassinât et de viols dans un parking
il est disculpé il y a tout juste un
mois il est arrêté puis relâché pour vol
du scooter conduit au commissariat il a
pu croiser ce portrait robot établi en
95 et qui ne le lui ressemble pas du
tout mais les enquêteurs disposaient
d'autres indices ce sweat shirt et
surtout une empreinte génétique qui a
conduit ce matin à l'arrestation de guy
georges retrouver un meurtrier dans une
agglomération comme paris près de 15
millions d'habitants c'est au départ
chercher une aiguille dans une meule de
foin
c'est pour cette raison que les
techniques de la police scientifique ont
désormais tous leurs intérêts dans cette
affaire
vous l'avez entendu les tests génétiques
da dn se sont révélés décisifs ainsi que
la participation de spécialistes
capables en regroupant des
renseignements les plus divers de
dresser un profil du coupable présumé
philippe visseyrias
10 décembre 1994 agnès michaux camper
retrouver violé et égorgé chez elle un
appartement qui donne dans une petite
cour du quartier de la bastille six mois
plus tard
elisabeth 25 ans est agressée à son
domicile elle réussit à s'échapper en
sautant par la fenêtre
une semaine après en juillet 1995 c'est
au tour d'hélène phreaking 27 ans violée
et assassinée dans le quartier de la
bastille dès cette époque les enquêteurs
de la brigade criminelle savent qu'ils
ont affaire à un tueur en série même
mode opératoire et surtout mêmes
empreintes génétiques
à peine deux mois plus tard dans le
cadre d'une autre enquête celle du
meurtre de la venue de rully la brigade
criminelle interroge 2000 personnes les
enquêteurs ne le savent pas encore parmi
les suspects se trouvent le tueur en
série on prélève ses empreintes
génétiques
mais impossible à cette époque de les
comparer à celles identifiées sur les
victimes du tueur de la bastille le dans
les laboratoires les scientifiques on a
pas de fichier et en ce moment il ya une
loi qui discuter au niveau du parlement
pour faire en france des fichiers
d'empreintes génétiques mais sun
concernerait pour l'instant que les
agressions sexuelles sur mineurs la
création d'un fichier central permettant
de comparer les empreintes génétiques
c'est ce que réclament tous les
spécialistes comme le professeur
bénézech qui a travaillé sur le profil
psychologique du tueur de la bastille il
faut vivre avec son temps
il est absolu mariana chronique d'avoir
un fichier pour les empreintes digitales
ce qui est important est de ne pas en
avoir pour les empreintes génétiques
alors que comme les empreintes digitales
elle donne quasiment une certitude
la dernière victime du tueur en série a
été retrouvée en novembre 1997 soit deux
ans après les prélèvements d'adé n sur
guy georges si un fichier central avait
existé regrette les enquêteurs elle
serait peut-être toujours en vie le
feuilleton politique des conseils
régionaux est loin d'être terminée pour
l'instant seul des cinq président udf
élu grâce à des voix du front national a
démissionné jean pierre soisson
président de la région bourgogne pour
autant cette démission n'a rien débloqué
reportage michaël darmon josé boulesteix
la session du conseil régional est
annulé mais les manifestants
maintiennent leur présence
car pour eux la démission de jean-pierre
soisson ne règle rien sur populaire la
révision de tous les présidents de
région élu graça désaccord avec le front
national
retour à la case départ en région
bourgogne cinq jours après son élection
avec l'appoint du front national jean
pierre soisson crack démissionne mais ne
renonce pas nous allons pour la
bourgogne continuer le combat politique
et je serai à nouveau candidat 2
l'ensemble des élus de l'opposition
retour à la case problème pour jean
pierre soisson
tour à tour il a été barriste mitterrand
disent aujourd'hui les partisans d'une
droite plurielle mais son rival en
bourgogne le rpr jean françois bazin a
encore l'intention de lui barrer la
route
il a été élu le 20 mars dans des
conditions que le chef de l'état
condamné et dans des conditions qu'ils
revendiquaient publiquement il prétend
aujourd'hui et trois nouveaux candidats
dans les mêmes conditions cela dépanne
mais cible à nos yeux
retour à la case réunion et tractations
la chasse aux voix est relancé en
bourgogne que feront les deux chasseurs
que feront les neuf élus du front
national pour l'instant silencieux la
gauche plurielle avec 24 sièges fait ses
comptes
si toutefois il venait à l'idée au fonds
national de voter pour moi j'enlève les
voix du front national il reste 24 et 24
c'est la majorité ici comme dans
d'autres régions les relations entre la
droite et le front national ont paralysé
le conseil régional alors la région
bourgogne serait-elle ingérable réponse
au prochain scrutin
le président udf de la région
midi-pyrénées marc censi élu lui aussi
grâce aux voix du front national qui
s'est déclaré démissionnaire des débuts
lui appelle à une solution beaucoup plus
radicale la dissolution des conseils
régionaux dans la mesure où nombre
d'entre eux n'ont pas de majorité
absolue
c'est incontestablement l'udf qui est la
plus déchirée par les conséquences de
ces élections régionales un de ses chefs
de file charles millon et hésite
toujours à démissionner en région rhône
alpes
le président du mouvement du df françois
léotard doit répondre aux tentatives
d'implosion lancée par françois bayrou
qui voudrait reconstruire un grand parti
au centre j'ai vite imbert jean-louis le
navire udf tank peut être très fort mais
il a encore un capitaine françois
léotard contre attaque et il règle ses
comptes
premièrement avec philippe séguin les
présidents de région udf élu grâce à
l'extrême droite n'ont aussi été avec
des voix rpr sur ordre de paris affirme
françois léotard
deuxièmement avec françois bayrou qui
veut créer un nouveau parti
on ne change pas les choses pour une
déclaration à la télévision si l'on dit
qu'il va y avoir des primaires entre le
rpr et l'udf à quoi sert-il de diviser
l'udf en deux en 3 ou en 4 morceaux et
bien sûr c'est une étrange conception
des choses
si comme le veut françois léotard toutes
les composantes du mouvement se
réunissent pour décider ou non de sa
survie certains courants parle déjà
comme françois bayrou de l'udf au passé
je crois que après vingt années
d'existence de l'udf il est temps de
prendre conscience des échecs et des
difficultés est donc l'heure est à une
refondation de notre formation politique
en attendant le mouvement n'a plus
vraiment d'autorité ce n'est pas à lui d
être mais au domicile de valéry giscard
d'estaing que charles millon est allé
recueillir ce matin la bonne parole
doit-il ou non démissionner de son
fauteuil de président de la région rhône
alpes l'ancien chef de l'état lui a
laissé le soin de décider sur l'avenir
de l'udf le mouvement qu'il a lui-même
fondé vge laisse également le jour où il
va je pense que malheureusement la
france est en déclin politique qu'à
l'heure actuelle la crise est très
profonde et on l'a vécu dans les jours
derniers et que son salut ne viendra pas
des mouvements des partis politiques
mais aussi du dr se réorganiser change
de nom nous avons pas d inconvénient
pour ce mouvement politique en tout cas
les jours qui viennent sont une question
de vie ou de disparition
françois bayrou bonsoir vous est ce soir
au centre des discussions politiques on
vient de le voir alors d'abord françois
léotard votre président qui estime que
votre initiative d'hier soir de créer un
parti au centre place de l'udf est une
aventure individuelle
ce n'est pas une initiative c'est un
appel j'ai été très frappée parce que le
président giscard d'estaing vient de
viens de dire est que nous avons
entendus ensemble
il a dit la france est dans une crise
politique très profonde
je crois qu'il a raison et je crois que
les mouvements politiques sur lesquelles
il a exprimé du scepticisme sont dans
une crise politique très profonde
il n'y a qu'une seule interrogation
est-ce qu'on reste les bras croisés sans
rien faire ou est-ce qu'au contraire on
essaie de relever le défi et d'en faire
quelque chose de nouveau et de forts en
soi bayrou est ce que vous avez ressenti
l'intervention monsieur giscard
d'estaing comme finalement les paroles
d'un homme assez indifférent à ce que
vous pourriez faire ou est ce que pour
vous ça vaut approbation de votre
initiative non je suis je suis certain
que monsieur giscard d'estaing n'est pas
indifférent je me suis souvent entretenu
de ce sujet avec lui je crois qu'il est
sceptique parce qu'il a l'impression que
jamais rien ne change et bien l'appel
que j'ai lancé qui n'est pas individuel
vous avez vu aujourd'hui se multiplier à
l'intérieur de l'udf les réactions dans
toutes les familles politiques d'élus
qui disent c'est un député des
alpes-maritimes rudy salles qui l'a dit
je crois le plus simplement il a dit
bayrou dit tout fort ce que tout le
monde pense tout bas je me suis la
raison françois bayrou est ce que c'est
contre françois léotard votre
intervention votre appel ou est-ce que
c'est avec lui il a l'air de penser que
c'est contre il parle d' aventure
individuelle
non je dois c'est vrai que c'était un
électrochoc que j'ai souhaité et c'est
vrai que c'est un appel que j'ai lancé
sans l'habituelle consultation à
laquelle l'udf est habitué depuis
cinquante ans alors juste un an jean
laquelle selon laquelle on discute
beaucoup et on n'avance jamais alors est
ce que c'est on avait justement est-ce
que vous allez vous allez aller au bout
de cette initiative ou bien est-ce que
c'était pour réveiller les consciences
il finance nous irons au bout je crois
que notre mouvement politique dans son
ensemble mais pas seulement on parle pas
ici de uniquement de d'organisation
politique on parle des français
j'ai été très frappée on recevait tony
blair à l'assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière il y avait de très vives
applaudissements sur tous les bancs je
dois dire honnêtement davantage à droite
qui viendrait à gauche mais tony blair
décrivait un projet qui était un projet
optimiste positif dans lequel il y avait
des valeurs morales en même temps qu'une
volonté de liberté et c'est vraiment
notre projet non je n'ai pas la fatuité
de dire le mien c'était notre projet il
n'y a personne pour le défendre en
france c'est formidable
voilà un pays qui a une démocratie de
vieille expérience dans laquelle on
mesure que personne n'est là pour
défendre un projet de bon sens et
réconciliateur au centre de la politique
alors blair c'est le centre gauche nous
c'est le centre droit mais on voit bien
qu'il y a une vraie chance une vraie
ouverture et que personne ne dit rien et
qu on se tait comme si on était enseveli
sous les appareils politiques qu'on ne
pourrait pas changer
et bien moi je crois qu'on peut les
changer je crois qu'on peut changer les
comportements
si j'ai une initiative brutale j'espère
que mes amis
finiront par comprendre qu'il fallait
bien et pardonneront même si entre nous
il n'ya pas exactement ce genre de
relation de pardon mais ils finiront par
comprendre et que tout le monde ensemble
va saisir le taureau par les cornes et
dire maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait je
suis persuadé que du mal que nous avons
vécu peut sortir un bien
merci venir françois bayrou premier
geste spectaculaire du nouveau préfet de
corse bernard bonnet qui demande la
destruction partielle du nouvel hôtel de
région dont trois permis de construire
ont été annulés sans que cela soit suivi
d'effets et puis la disparition de rené
andrieu à 60 18 ans qui fume pendant un
quart de siècle
le rédacteur en chef du journal
communiste l'humanité il était considéré
comme un fidèle parmi les fidèles de
georges marchais aux etats unis les
fabricants de cigarettes on le sait sont
dans le collimateur de bon nombre
d'associations en france pour la
première fois c'est une caisse primaire
de maladie de saint nazaire qui envisage
de porter plainte contre eux les
manufactures de tabac
il faut dire que dans cette région la
moyenne de la mortalité dues au
tabagisme est supérieur de 11% au reste
du pays lors le job
michel aulas la caisse d'assurance
maladie de saint nazaire sera peut-être
à l'origine d'une première juridique en
france elle n'est pour l'heure qu'un
empêcheurs de tourner en rond
son directeur annonce une action en
justice contre les cigarettiers
mais il n'en connaît ni les fondements
ni la date en fait il se bat seulement
sur un constat tient de surmortalité
édenté et des morts considéré équitable
avant 65 ans eh bien les hommes sont
dans une situation où beaucoup poussent
à laser qu'ailleurs puisque 14% par
rapport à la menace est là et que sur
ces morts évitables une grande partie
est malheureusement trop grande partie
est imputable directement à de mauvaises
habitudes notamment au tabagisme
la caisse de saint nazaire compte
demander réparation pour ce qu'elle
estime être un préjudice financier
mais avant de se porter devant un
tribunal il va lui falloir plusieurs
mois d'un travail minutieux
la position pro minimale sers-toi
établir le coût des soins et des
indemnités effectivement versées à des
assurés de cette caisse dont il serait
démontré que leur affection sont liées
au tabac au tabagisme
un tel recensement n'existe à ce jour
dans aucune caisse d'assurance maladie
de france un grand procès à l'américaine
n'est donc pas pour demain
le jeu en vaudrait pourtant probablement
la chandelle certains estiment le coût
nationale des pathologies liées au tabac
à près de 100 milliards de francs par an
les enseignants du département de la
seine-saint-denis ne se démobilise pas
nouvelle manifestation à paris
aujourd'hui en compagnon en compagnie
pardon de lycéens et de parents d'élèves
il s'agit pour eux d'obtenir
principalement des postes d'enseignants
supplémentaires dans un département qui
bénéficie déjà d'une expérience pilote
pour tenter de remettre l'école à niveau
dans les quartiers difficiles
santé le medec le salon s'est ouvert à
paris le thème cette année
l'alimentation les spécialistes
américains sont venus dire aux français
qu'ils nous enviait la variété de notre
alimentation qui est sans doute l'une
des raisons de notre meilleure santé par
rapport à eux
malheureusement nous aussi nous évoluons
vers un type de nourriture beaucoup trop
uniforme
stéphane haumant france vaillant chaud
devant
manger équilibré c'est bien manger varié
c'est mieux selon plusieurs études de
nutritionnistes les français consomment
une trentaine d'aliments différents
chaque semaine
ce répertoire peut aller parfois jusqu'à
50 aliments c'est beaucoup si l'on
compare avec les américains en moyenne
il ne consomme que 3 aliments différents
par jour 5 ou 6 sur une semaine cette
uniformité n'est pas bonne pour la santé
et la voc de l'alléger ne change rien à
la fête il faut manger varié sûrement
jeu
petite quantité les halles légers
peuvent aider à réduire certains risques
d'excès d'accord mais la variété la
diversification de notre alimentation
sans aucun doute un des éléments les
plus favorables
on re découvre même les vertus
diététiques de la soupe en début de mois
pas elle coupe le gros appétit 8 % des
foyers français en consomment assidûment
bien sûr nous continuons à manger trop
gras et trop sucrés mais notre taux de
maladies cardiovasculaires est bien
inférieur à celui des américains
c'est ce qu'ils appellent paradoxe
français ça passionne des américains
parce qu'ici en france qu'on mange bien
on fume compte une tranche à
on fait pas l'exercice physique mais
quand même qualité des big bang on vit
longtemps pouvoir manger vite partout et
à n'importe quelle heure c'est la
nouvelle demande des consommateurs
français les américains eux découvrent
les vertus de notre vin consommé avec
modération
ils viennent donc de lancer c'est très
sérieux une pilule aux extraits de vin
rouge a avalé en fin de repas votre
regard sur les français l'institut
national de la statistique révèle une
étude portant sur 6000 personnes et qui
montre que hormis les conversations
téléphoniques nous parlons nous nous
parlons de moins en moins et encore 15
ans 60% des français déclarent avoir eu
déclaré avoir eu une discussion directe
au cours de la semaine
ils sont moins de 45 % aujourd'hui la
situation économique y est sans doute
pour quelque chose
jean jacques dufour france fait rien
dans cette france que l'on dit douce non
seulement les gens se parlent de moins
en moins mais en plus ils ont peur de
s'exprimer
l'une des conséquences du chômage c'est
un goût de plomb dans la bouche
annick en a fait l'amère expérience
désormais le devant de la scène
elle préfère laisser aux autres airs
actuelle et agout longtemps et en dvd
la peur la solitude c'est aussi le
quotidien de michel en étant licencié de
chez skype en 93 elle a perdu non
seulement son emploi mais aussi l'amitié
de ses collègues il au lit quand je
rencontre dans les magasins je lance me
lis pourtant dire bonjour comment
va-t-il mai puis tout ça tout à fait à
nos membres du camp du non
wade il ya beaucoup plus de solidarité
entre chômeurs actuellement qu'entre
gens de travail
ces mêmes égards celle qui travaillons
entre elles sont jalouses de jaloux les
gens parce qu'elle est une paye de plus
sous l'autel des plus belles maisons et
tout ça moi je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de solidarité autres chômeurs
contre genre actif est la souffrance
comment et pourquoi la loi du silence
fonctionne si bien dans notre société
c'est le sujet du livre de christophe
dejours beaucoup de gens ne parlent pas
parce qu'ils ne croient plus que les
autres sont prêts à entendre et ces
conditions-là soda paroles sont
effectivement dans de nombreuses
organisations ruiner
du petit qui parle parle tout seul les
autres ne veulent pas entendre c'est
comme pour la dame dont par est alors on
ne la regarde pas de façon ne veut pas
entendre
la peur ne rend pas seulement aveugle
elle rend aussi sourd gens n'entendent
pas au foot comme s'il n'entendait pas
de la chape de plomb qui pèse sur le
monde du travail
josé peut témoigner si son quotidien
c'est vrai il ya la peur qui est ancrée
chez les gens qui m'appellent bon et
après pour être comme je disais je vais
distribuer des tracts dans certaines
entreprises où il ya pas d'instance
sénégal et on voit les gens qui qui rend
tête baissée nos entreprises qui n'ose
pas en parler de peur que la hiérarchie
des voies à l'entrée discuter bien ils
ne prennent pas les tracts alors bondé
les gros pas forcément l'entreprise
dans ces conditions prenez le tous unis
n'est pas facile tous les jours chez
sprague mille ouvriers il y a dix en
moins d'une centaine aujourd'hui les
rescapés de la dernière section
connaissent bien le problème avec la
mondialisation la solidarité ouvrière
c'est chacun portant un prénom à mon
avis ce soir c'est déjà sa revue mal
enchaîné
voilà en gros l'idée c'est qu'il faut
sauver ça pour quoi on servait de rêve
dure comme ça
quand j'entends parfois
c'est moche ces matches il
dans cette france que l'on dit douce la
parole est d'argent mais apparemment le
silence est d'or
actuellement se tient à paris le salon
des thermalies bien que la sécurité
sociale soit de plus en plus regardante
les français aiment les cures par
exemple l'an dernier six cent mille
personnes sont passées par un centre de
thalassothérapie des établissements qui
rivalisent d'imagination pour attirer
les clients ainsi le centre de roscoff
en bretagne propose désormais une
thalasso des dents vous avez bien
entendu des dents marie-hélène bono
alain points l'institut marin battu par
les vents chargés diodes llyod la base
de toutes les cures proposé en option
les dents de la mer un soins
bucco-dentaires mise au point par des
médecins de roscoff loup de mer est un
véritable médicament un antibiotique
naturel
elle apaise les gencives prévient les
caries et le déchaussement c'est une
douche filiforme qui irrigue les gens
sur les gencives supérieur et les
gencives inférieur chaque séance dure
dix minutes l'eau de mer sous pression
stimule la circulation sanguine des
insectes et nettoie là où la brosse à
dents ne va pas on est mieux d de la
première séance s'est pas trop d énergie
vous allez vous parler flamand débâcle
main mais fait plus efficace pour
valoriser son activité le centre utilise
toutes les ressources locales
le bord de mer le climat surtout et
saufs en même temps ce qu'il veut le
reprendre une activité sportive il
propose la curieux de plus la porte un
plus comme on le dit à la cure
traditionnelle à savoir une oxygénation
à retour au milieu marin et à un
environnement qui est extrêmement
sédatifs et ça les groupes dépasse
rarement 400 personnes
conseillé par un éducateur sportif les
curistes prennent leur pouls évaluent
leurs capacités physiques avec des
exercices mais aussi des conseils de
base
il est quelquefois préférable si on veut
courir une demi-heure de courir
peut-être 20 minutes et de faire dix
minutes d'étirements pour accompagner
son exercice physique
on en tirera bien meilleur profit ce
type de cure n'est plus remboursé par la
sécurité sociale
face à la concurrence les centres
doivent diversifier leur séjour roscoff
table sur l'une de ses spécialités le
palper-rouler il s'agit de soulever
implique beau et le mobiliser sur toute
la zone sont amassés dans le but
d'éliminer les toxines des tissus chaque
année 4000 personnes environ subtil cure
à roscoff
c'est le premier centre de thalasso
ouvert en europe en 1999 il fêtera ses
100 ans
à trois mois de la coupe du monde de
football l'une des préoccupations
majeures des organisateurs restent la
sécurité dans les stades
les anglais qui ont eu avant les autres
à connaître ce type de problème ont
appliqué une méthode dont nous pourrions
nous inspirer ils ont estimé que la
sécurité devait être confiée à des
professionnels autour et dans les stades
et pas seulement à des policiers c'est
notre enquête de ce soir londres etienne
c'est une véritable petite armée avec
ses chefs ces fantassins et ses lois
ce jour là pour une simple rencontre de
deuxième division le club des queens
park rangers sa tante de ses 300
stadiers qu'ils contiennent les quinze
mille supporteurs attendus aucun d'entre
eux n'est bénévoles troch wipro staff et
les personnes pour assurer la sécurité
pendant les rencontres ce qui nous
revient à 60 mille francs par match à
peu près nostalgie et sont rémunérés ce
sont des professionnels ils sont là pour
un travail et pas pour regarder le match
de fait pour 200 francs l'après-midi les
stewards vont vivre le match dos au
terrain depuis les drames successifs qui
ont secoué le football britannique les
grilles ont disparu des enceintes des
stades et la vigilance est de rigueur
la règle de toute façon était simple
s'il jette un oeil sur la rencontre ils
seront licenciés sur le champ cette
rigueur la n'empêche pas les incidents
il y à un mois une stade hier a été
envoyé à l'hôpital par un supporter
envahissant et ce ne sont pas des
occasionnels qui empêcheront les joueurs
impulsif de régler directement leur
compte mais la casse et limites tout en
éveillant individus sur 40000 décide
d'aller sur la pelouse
on ne peut pas faire grand chose il y a
toujours ce risque en revanche on avait
prévu après le démantèlement des
barrières des invasions de masse les
pelouse mais elles ne se sont pas
produites
les supporters sont aujourd'hui beaucoup
mieux éduqués disciplinés par les clubs
ce que ne dit pas le commissaire chapman
c'est qu'à côté de l'éducation la police
anglaise a mis en place dans tous les
stades du pays un système de
surveillance sophistiqués plus de
quarante caméras capables de localiser
jusqu'à la moindre bouteille de boisson
gazeuse dans chacun des 92 clubs
professionnels un policier est chargé à
l'année de suivre les supporters
regardez cet après midi là les
responsables de la sécurité ont
immédiatement repéré le doute
comportement de ces deux jeunes hommes
dès lors ils ne vont plus les lâches
en quelques secondes si wars et mobiles
sont prévenus et ils vont en douceur les
interpeller tous les samedis
l'information de tous les clubs du
royaume remonte à londres vers l'unité
de scotland yard
spécialisée dans la lutte anti hooligans
on connaît très bien les fauteurs de
troubles dans les stades
il ne suffit de dessiner et avec une
petite équipe de policiers
on peut les empêcher de semer la
pagaille a observé le véritable arsenal
saisi ces derniers mois sur les pseudos
amateurs de football on a du mal
toutefois à croire la statistique
officielle
deux à trois cents jeunes seulement
serez véritablement dangereux ils sont
connus fiché mais la loi anglaise ne
peut les empêcher de se rendre en france
au mois de juin prochain
ce qu'on peut offrir à nos collègues
français c'est toute l'information que
nous avons non
la terre donc quand ces personnages se
déplacent dans les terres en france dans
le sauras tu avances les pouvant
prévenir nos amis français allemand fort
de ce spot publicitaire tourné en france
à marseille
la grande-bretagne conseil depuis
quelques jours à ses supporteurs de ne
pas se rendre en france en billets
d'entrée et de se souvenir que ces
billets seront nominatifs
tout faire en quelque sorte pour éviter
des incidents comme ceux de roms à
l'automne dernier éparpillés dans les
tribunes les supporteurs britannique
turbulent avait été copieusement
matraqués par la police italienne
l'actualité internationale ça mais
franco germano russe aujourd'hui à
moscou jacques chirac
helmut kohl veulent tarim et la russie à
l'europe avec de grands projets comme
une autoroute londres moscou doublé d'un
réseau de voies ferrées une réunion qui
a commencé par une bourde de boris
helsinki donne nouvelle fois la preuve
que son état de santé varient parfois
d'une heure à l'autre moscou gilles
rabin jean-françois l ouverture de ce
sommet à trois boris eltsine ne paraît
pas au mieux de sa fille il se tromper
au lieu d'ouvrir les discussions il
ouvre la conférence de presse qui
normalement devait clore le sommet
embarras du chancelier kohl et du
président jacques chirac
le porte parole du kremlin tente de
remettre le président russe sur les
rails mais boris eltsine veut sa
conférence de presse tout de suite et
ils célèbrent déjà la force et la
solidité du nouvel axe paris pomme
moscou
deux heures d'entretien plus tard la
nouvelle troïka diplomatique et les cas
il n'y a plus de points noirs hall
cadeaux il n'ya plus que l'amitié olc
mire
il n'ya plus que l'artillerie et sur le
continent et la grande europe
jacques chirac précise la passe de yalta
dit il
et tourner les jeux diplomatiques
pervers qui historiquement marqué les
relations entre la russie l'allemagne et
la france ne sont plus d'actualité pour
marquer symboliquement cette nouvelle
entente boris eltsine a offert à chacun
de ces réseaux tse 3 et qu elles réunies
au centre par un petit club qui donne
essentielle de ce sommet était de
rassurer la grande est susceptible
russie sur sa place et son rôle en
europe irak respecte le traité signé
avec des nations unies les inspecteurs
ont pu ce matin commencer la visite des
sites présidentielle supposé abriter des
armements interdite qui doit être
détruit au terme des accords signés
après la guerre du golfe
ces sites sont au nombre de 8 sur le
territoire irakien
point d'orgue de son périple africain le
président bill clinton est arrivé en
afrique du sud où il a été accueilli par
hammerson mandela le président lors de
ces premières étapes bill clinton a
demandé pardon pour la traite des noirs
à destination des plantations du sud des
états unis il a également demandé que la
démocratie soit respectée sur le
continent africain
mais l'amérique veut surtout faire des
affaires avec l'afrique
eric magnin trois boeing 747 comme celui
ci un hélicoptère blindé
une dizaine de voitures 800 invités des
services de sécurité qui prépare depuis
des mois ce que la presse américaine a
baptisé l'odyssée africaine des clinton
voilà pour les moyens ils sont hollywood
quant au scénario une histoire d'amour à
l'eau de rose bill clinton m l'afrique
l'afrique
m bill clinton le continent noir
serait-il devenu fréquent talent
après un siècle de différence c'est en
tout cas le nouveau discours de
l'administration clinton
avec cette tournée historique rappelant
qu'un président n'avait foulé le sol
africain dans un voyage officiel
voilà ce que clinton peut faire oublier
des images de détresse ou pire pour les
américains celle du corps de leurs
soldats tués et profanes et 7 et en
somalie en 1993
cinq ans plus tard clinton est en
afrique affichant ostensiblement bonheur
est optimiste c'est une bonne opération
de politique intérieure est la
principale raison de ce voyage il ne
faut pas oublier que près de 40 millions
d'américains ont des racines africaines
il ne faut pas oublier non plus
cette réalité africaine 700 millions de
consommateurs et une économie plus
prospères qu'on ne le croit sept pour
cent de croissance l'an dernier
trade not aid c'est la doctrine clinton
l'amérique doit commercer avec les
africains pas leur faire la charité
un discours qui a le don d'agacer par la
france premier partenaire économique de
l'afrique avec ses 1500 entreprises sur
place
la france qui distribue chaque année 20
milliards dette publique sur le
continent trois fois plus que les
américains la france que les sourires de
clinton irrite plus qu'il d'impression
la france est le pays des bons et des
mauvais jours en afrique c'est à dire
que nous ne repartons pas dès qu'il ya
une difficulté
l'africain qui sont des gens très
réaliste verrons si les américains
repartent à la première difficulté mais
il faut du temps et jurent haut pour
autant les entreprises américaines sont
elles prêtes à déferler
ce n'est sans doute pas pour tout de
suite il leur faudra d'abord apprendre à
connaître l'afrique avant d'y évoluer
sans risque de chavirer des
paléontologues italiens annoncent la
découverte d'un des dinosaures les mieux
conservés du monde vieux de plus de 110
millions d'années pour la première fois
il l'aurait constitués et les organes
tels que les muscles sont en bon état de
conservation et vont pouvoir être
observée
un record du monde inattendu celui de la
vitesse en vélo sur neige à vars dans
les hautes-alpes vitesses atteintes un
peu plus de 212 km heure christophe
tordra record battu mais que d'efforts
pour en arriver là à la montagne c'est
bien connu avant les joies de la
descente il faut monter et ce matin à
vars pour christian taillefer
cela n'a pas été de tout repos une
nacelle tractée par une dameuse
et le voilà en plein milieu de la piste
prêts à s'élancer pour battre le record
du monde de vitesse à vélo et vu la
pente il faut chaud être totalement
inconscient soit s'être entraîné depuis
des mois christian taillefer n'a rien
laissé au hasard
cvc en soufflerie lui ont permis
d'améliorer son taux de pénétration dans
l'air
christian à sept titres de champion de
france de vtt
il a lui-même conçu ce vélo destinés
uniquement records chaque prototype
coûte 100 mille francs pièce qu'un en
aluminium suspension hydraulique
il restait un détail à régler leur
problème c'est le freinage on avait
toujours eu des problèmes auparavant
avec des disques de série en aluminium
en acier il déforme et histoire d un
avait énormément de mal à s'arrêter
donc cette année ce qu'on a fait on a
travaillé énormément sur les dix qui
utilisent les mêmes matières gt1 formule
1 savoir le disque en carbone qui peut
monter très haut en température ça nous
permet de vous faire cerrone en toute
sécurité
ce matin pourtant il est venu inspecter
une dernière fois la décence plus aucune
bosse sur la piste de chabrières au jour
j tout est fin prêt contrairement aux
autres disciplines où je dirais que
l'effort physique prime sur la
psychologie
là par contre le mental à rôles qui est
vraiment très importante
environ 80% psychologique et 20% de
physique
212 km heure une vitesse grisante la
prochaine fois christian espère
atteindre les 220 km/heure sur son vélo
il en rêve déjà
le plus célèbre des pianistes de jazz
français michel petrucciani parcourt le
monde en permanence les plus grands
jouent avec lui après six années
d'absence il revient en france après
l'olympia nous l'avons filmé il a
entrepris une grande tournée un
spectacle à couper le souffle
le 15 ou guillon [ __ ]
un rappel endiablé après plus de deux
heures de concert à la veille d'une
tournée qui va l'emmener jusqu'à l'été
lorsque michel petrucciani célèbre ses
retrouvailles avec la france même son
piano a du mal à suivre le rythme
un rythme qui s'affiche désormais en
lettres capitales et qui lui laisse peu
de temps pour goûter l'air de paris au
printemps car le plus célèbre de nos
pianiste de jazz vie entre deux avions à
new york city de quoi donner un vrai
goût de madeleine à la promenade parmi
les souvenirs des tout premiers concerts
vous avez beaucoup et mon père je vais
avoir 8 9 ans et on faisait des salles
en faisait des restaurants faisait des
des clubs on faisait des animations
après les cas j'avais 14 15 ans je me
souviens on allait jouer dans les restos
ont disent écoutez ou fait à manger à
tous mes potes et puis on vous une heure
une heure et demie lui que deux heures
et voilà on faisait on faisait de leurs
la vie c'était ce à quoi
quinze ans après son premier voyage
outre atlantique payer avec à chaque en
bois michel petrucciani est une star de
tous les côtés de l'océan et ce qui n'a
pas changé c'est l'amitié dont il a fait
la clé de ces partitions avec des
musiciens aussi prestigieux que le
batteur steve gadd comme avec les
copains d'enfance à orange respecte bien
sûr il m'impressionne
parce qu'il parle français anglais
italien et même un peu d'allemand
surtout son sens du rythme sa musique
est universelle joe cole un rythme
incroyable un sens musical capable de
donner en solo des airs de caf de jazz
hot ouvelle olympia
e
et lorsqu il achève une improvisation de
45 minutes
il tient à faire saluer son piano par le
public si michel petrucciani est
étonnant c'est surtout par sa modestie
avant nous quitter le rappel du
principal titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi après plusieurs mois de traque le
tueur présumé de cette femme en reste
parisien été arrêté aujourd'hui depuis
24 heures quatre cents policiers étaient
à ses trousses dans la capitale dans un
instant la météo de sophie davant que
vous vous retrouvez je vous le rappelle
encore une fois désormais chaque jour
avant le journal ensuite le point route
ou valérie maurice 20h55 mais ne soit
reinfo avec envoyé spécial
et puis ensuite le monde foot à 23h10
présenté par gérard holtz demain 7h 50
dans les 4 vérités
marie pierre farkas recevoir le
professeur christian cabrol puis à 20h
vous retrouverez béatrice schönberg vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur la
chaîne
envoyée